took everybody in the platoona side and
I said listen I've had one-on-one
conversations with every single one of
you you are all struggling with things
in different different things and in
different ways I will never talk about
any of our conversations with anybody
else it's not it's not for public
knowledge you know all we did and I it
was grow up showing either strength or
perceived strength and and this was kind
of like weakness you know the guys who
would you know beat their chest and say
no effing way am I talking to the
chaplain and blah blah blah and I was
just like okay the way to get through
this is make everybody do it and
there'll be no Stigma for who did and
who didn't talk and and um and uh there
wasn't a single person who didn't talk
less than several hours to each of the
psych in the chaplain we had to extend
them there for a couple weeks and and
really I think set the foundation for a
couple things number one is for each of
those guys in their own lives as they
dealt with you know the post-traumatic
stress of of doing the body recoveries
from the downed helicopter and putting
their buddies in bags and bringing them
home